vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir le rapport
explosif des Nations Unies qui révèle
que les militaires maliens et les
groupes djihadistes se sont rendus
coupables de massacres et d'exactions au
Mali entre juillet et septembre au total
on parle de plus de 375 cas de violation
des droits de l'homme
Sadio Mane ira au Qatar c'est le
sélectionneur des Lions de la Téranga
qui s'est dit optimistes quant à la
participation de l'international
sénégalais au Mondial de football dans
une dizaine de jours et c'est tout un
pays qui reprend son souffle nous irons
sur place
et notre invité de ce soir est une
écrivaine de talent congolaise et
roumaine après le succès de son premier
roman elle confirme avec un deuxième
opus plus en ambitieux où elle fait
l'éloge d'un combat féministe et
écologiste Annie et avec nous pour notre
plus grand plaisir et elle publie la
peine des faunes
on ouvre ce journal par le rapport à
l'armant publié par les Nations unies au
sujet du Mali l'ONU révèle que les
militaires maliens et les groupes
djihadistes ont commis des massacres et
des exactions contre des civils entre
juillet et septembre les détails avec
Fanny Chauvin depuis New York
c'est un rapport terrifiant que l'ONU
vient de publier l'Organisation des
Nations Unies à répertorié
375 violations des droits humains au
Mali entre juillet et septembre parmi
ces violations on trouve des viols des
disparitions ou encore des meurtres en
masse dans des villages je citerai
l'exemple du village de Gouny dans le
centre du Mali ou une cinquantaine de
personnes ont été tuées par des
militaires étrangers accompagnés de
chasseurs traditionnels selon le rapport
toujours selon l'ONU les responsables de
ces crimes sont les militaires maliens
ou encore les djihadistes les gros
djihadistes et la milice Wagner proche
du Kremlin Bamako assure pourtant ouvrir
des enquêtes systématiquement mais les
résultats les conclusions de ces
investigations ne sont pratiquement
jamais rendu public ce rapport de l'ONU
ne risque donc pas d'arranger des
relations déjà 30 tendues entre Bamako
et ses partenaires le ministre des
Affaires étrangères Abdoulaye Diop a
déjà critiqué l'ONU et accusé la France
d'avoir commis des actes d'accrétion et
d'espionnage au manie Bamako ont un qui
souhaite la tenue d'une réunion du
Conseil de sécurité pour présenter je
cite ses preuves mais pour le moment son
appel n'a pas été entendu
en République démocratique du Congo de
violents combats opposés ce vendredi
l'armée congolaise au rebelle lui M23
dans l'est du pays au moment où le
président angolais désignait médiateur
continuait à chercher une solution
diplomatique à la crise entre Kinshasa
et Kigali
la justice au Tchad a annoncé vendredi
que plus de 600 personnes dont 83
mineurs ont été arrêtés lors des
manifestations de l'opposition réprimées
dans le sang le 20 octobre à Yamina les
accusés d'avoir attaqué les institutions
pour mener une insurrection l'opposition
et une partie de la communauté
internationale à fermement condamné à
recours excessif à la violence contre
les civils
plus d'un an après les interventions des
forces de sécurité rwandaises aux
Mozambique la situation sécuritaire
reste fragile au Cabo Delgado les
groupes djihadistes se sont repliés dans
l'Est et le Sud de la province et
continue de mener des attaques contre
les populations le point avec le
renversé cher
quelques habitants déambulent dans les
rues poussiéreuses de qui onga sous le
regard des forces de sécurité rwandaise
lourdement armée un an après sa
libération ce village du nord du
Mozambique porte encore les séquelles de
l'insurrection djihadiste
s'améliorent les gens sont libres de se
déplacer on peut aller à l'école acheter
ce qu'on veut donc ça va un peu près
province pauvres du nord du Mozambique
le Cabo Delgado est depuis 5 ans la
cible de groupe armés affiliés à l'état
islamique tombé aux mains des rebelles
le village de kyonga était devenu l'une
de leurs bases d'opérations jusqu'à
l'intervention de l'armée rwandaise en
août 2021
mais alors que certains habitants
commencent aujourd'hui à rentrer chez
eux la situation sécuritaire reste
volatile et le départ des troupes
rondelles n'est pour l'instant pas
d'actualité
la prochaine étape sera de voir si les
forces de sécurité mozambiken peuvent
être réformés pour qu'elles puissent
assurer la sécurité dans ces zones après
le départ des forces rwandaises
mais je ne pense pas pouvoir donner de
calendrier car c'est un long processus
qui est toujours en cours
chasser des grandes villes les
djihadistes n'ont pour autant pas
disparu la plupart se sont dispersés
dans des campagnes et continuent de
mener des attaques contre les
populations civiles au cabot d'algado
et on passe à cette bonne nouvelle pour
tout un pays Sadio Mane ira au Qatar
malgré sa blessure c'est le
sélectionneur des Lions de la terre enga
à Lucie C qui a tenu à rassurer les fans
sénégalais quant à la participation de
l'international sénégalais la Coupe du
Monde du Qatar qui s'ouvre le 20
novembre Sarah Sakho
c'est le ouf de soulagement au Sénégal
depuis l'annonce des 26 joueurs
sélectionnés pour le Qatar et sur la
liste figure donc Sadio Mané blessée
mardi au genou alors un doute plein
encore sur sa participation
effectivement c'est le coach Aliou Cissé
lui-même qu'il a dit devant la presse ce
vendredi je n'ai pas envie de parler de
l'absence de Sadio Mané même si au fond
de ma tête je m'y prépare en attendant
dans les rues de Dakar l'heure est à
l'optimisme je vous propose d'écouter
ses réactions
de Sadio Mane et l'ensemble de l'équipe
nationale face nous avons des lions
partout des gens qui jouent au niveau
de retrouver la santé même s'ils ne
dispute que deux ou trois matchs on est
preneur
moi j'ai confiance à nos jours ils vont
gagner le match
il va vous ramener le couple aussi pour
le reste pas de grande surprise dans
cette sélection nationale c'est
pratiquement le même groupe qui a
remporté la Coupe d'Afrique des nations
en début d'année avec ou sans Sadio Mané
les Lions de la terre en guerre
disputeront leur premier match le 21
novembre prochain et ce sera contre les
Pays-Bas
on passe à la culture et notre invité
est pleinement écrivain après son succès
fulgurant pour son premier roman La Mer
Noire dans les Grands Lacs pour lequel
nous l'avions reçu et pour notre plus
grand plaisir elle confirme avec son
deuxième opus la peine des faune un
grand roman ambitieux où elle expose
j'allais dire toutes ces lubies non mais
en tout cas c'est grands thèmes aussi
bien l'écologie que le féminisme
bienvenue Annie Lulu ravi de vous
accueillir à nouveau dans le journal
alors dans ce roman ce nouveau roman
vous raconter l'histoire d'une lignée de
femme à travers le temps et encore une
fois j'ai envie de dire le roman s'ouvre
donc avec ce lien de maternité de notre
mère et une fille
Gnagna et Maggie la fille des relations
qui se passent pas bien
comment est né cette histoire d'abord
pour commencer
peine défaut n'est née à partir d'un
personnage qui est une des descendantes
donc de ces deux premières héroïnes
elle était 2019 donc à l'époque je
n'avais jamais été publié je ne savais
même pas que mon premier roman serait
publié un jour mais j'ai prouvé vraiment
l'urgence de décrire ce personnage avec
qui d'ailleurs j'ai pas du tout aimé
cohabiter au départ jusqu'à ce qu'elle
finisse par trouver sa place dans cette
lignée de femme et qu'elle devienne
elle-même une femme remarquable il
s'agit du personnage de Gina j'avais en
tête
l'idée que ce que j'éprouvais dans ma
vie à l'époque en tant que femme et
aussi en termes de réflexion politique
notamment
coexister ou devait essayer de d'exister
à l'intérieur de mon travail et donc
cette réflexion sur la condition
féminine et à la fois cette réflexion
sur l'urgence écologique dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui est venu
comme ça sont venus s'entremêler à
l'intérieur de peine défaut même si ce
n'était pas le projet de départ oui
justement ça c'est intéressant donc ce
roman est aussi pleinement politique
vous l'avez dit
justement pour vous est-ce que c'est une
évidence de lier la cause féministe à la
cause écologiste justement pas du tout
au contraire ce sont deux questions qui
d'habitude sont prises de façon
complètement distincte dans nos sociétés
alors qu'en fait on le voit de plus en
plus notamment avec la jeunesse qui se
mobilise dans le monde pour le climat en
ce moment c'est la cop27 on peut voir
dans le manifester absolument des jeunes
hommes et des jeunes femmes surtout du
monde entier qui font le lien entre la
question de la condition féminine la
violence exercée contre les femmes et de
la violence exercée
contre la planète alors ça peut paraître
un peu général comme ça de dire contre
la planète mais en réalité on parle de
des activités violentes d'extraction de
de fractures minières et ainsi de suite
on parle également des activités
violentes contre les autres corps que
les corps des êtres humains et notamment
contre les animaux avec qui nous
partageons avec qui nous partageons
cette planète parce que dans votre livre
il y a un des personnages justement qui
dit que les tueurs de d'animaux sont
aussi des tueurs de femmes en fait qui
font un parallèle il y a un parallèle
qui est fait entre celui qui peut tuer
une femme donc faire des féminicides
parce qu'il est question de féminicides
aussi dans le livre et aussi tuer des
animaux il y a même un parallèle sur le
fait de découper de la viande carrément
en fait à l'intérieur de cette lignée de
femme qui sont des femmes qui vont
chacune vers l'émancipation qui ont des
caractères très forts très affirmés des
personnalités bien marquées et bien
l'une d'entre elles va être assassinée
et on va suivre chacune de ces femmes de
l'arrière-grand-mère jusqu'à l'arrière
sont aussi une partie de la solution oui
absolument et là c'est intéressant parce
que votre livre il y a donc une phrase
qui qui marque qui dit que les femmes
donc les hommes en prennent pour leur
grade forcément mais que les femmes ne
sont pas épargnées non plus et que les
femmes élèvent les tueurs et vous dites
les femmes il y a un des personnages qui
disent les femmes élèvent les tueurs ce
qui est quand même et elles élèves aussi
les protecteurs tout à fait la fin en
fait il y a toute une réflexion donc par
ces par ces femmes de génération en
génération sur comment est-ce que cela a
pu arriver dans notre famille et on
parle d'une famille plutôt matriarcale
avec des traditions très spécifiques
j'ai eu envie de faire de ces
personnages des super héroïnes certaines
ont quasiment des super pouvoirs ou des
pouvoirs un petit peu magiques sont très
engagés dans la vie ont vraiment des
parcours de vie extrêmement forts en
fait pour leur époque pour leur temps
pour leur contexte social politique
culturels on démarre à harucha qui est
quand même la ville en Tanzanie en
Tanzanie la ville extraordinaire où se
sont réunis tous les grands indépendant
qui est quand même un emblème de liberté
sur le continent et donc c'est ces
femmes à un moment donné on faire le
lien entre l'animalisation de leur corps
par la violence que l'une d'entre elles
notamment va subir pendant de nombreuses
années sans que personne n'arrive à
enrayer ce qui va finir par la tuer
entre l'animalisation de leur corps le
fait qu'on animalise pour inférioriser
et donc tout naturellement la matriarche
de la famille la vieille homme RA décide
de lutter contre la construction d'un
pipeline dans son village d'un oléoduc
qui est actuellement en construction aux
Tanzanie d'ailleurs on parle de l'icônes
[Musique]
s'attache physiquement pour simplement
pour nous pour nos terres pour notre
famille pour nos voisins je le fais pour
nous toutes les créatures car toutes les
créatures sont affectées par l'activité
violente de l'être humain et donc il y a
le fait de mêler
les conditions féminines et la condition
animale alors bien sûr les tueurs en
prennent pour leur grade les fauneurs
les bonheurs comme les appels dans le
dans le roman mais c'est aussi une
réflexion à partir de celui ou celle qui
est infériorisé qui est animalisé et
d'ailleurs on le remarque dans les
discours de haine dans les discours
racistes ou dans les discours misogynes
souvent l'être qui est infériorisée on
va utiliser un vocabulaire animalisant
contre absolument pour le dégradé
absolument merci Annie Lulu n'ont aucun
roman sur l'urgence écologiste qui
défend évidemment le combat féministe un
roman à lire que je vous conseille
vraiment peine des faune c'est publié
c'est Julia merci beaucoup d'être venu
c'est ainsi qu'on close au journal de
l'Afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivi et ben de Kinshasa donc du Congo
jusqu'en Roumanie en passant par Paris
on oublie personne restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur France 24
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
différents groupes de migrants sont
arrivés au cours des trois derniers
jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]